في باريس كما ترون الامور هادئه جدا حتى
الان الموكب يسير بكل هدوء ولا يوجد هناك
اشتباكات لكن الاشتباكات كما ذكرت انت
تتركز في مدينه نوت وايضا فيرين وكذلك
ايضا قبل قليل وردت معلومات عن اشتباكات
في مدينه ليون في وسط جنوب فرنسا قام
المتظاهرون باستهداف واجهات عدد من
المصارف هناك فبدات الاشتباكات هذه عموما
هي الحاله الامنيه في معظم المناطق حتى
الان الترقب الاكبر هو في باريس كيف ستؤول
اليه الامور خصوصا في ساعات المساء من
المحتمل ان تكون الاشتباكات كبيره في
باريس وايضا خصوصا مع دخول الطلاب على خط
هذه الازمه وهم بداوا بتنظيم تحركاتهم
بشكل مستقل على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
يقولون انهم يشاركون في تظاهرات التي تقوم
بها النقابات لكن ايضا هناك تحركهم الخاص
الذي يبدا عاده في ساعات المساء الاولى في
الليل يقومون باشعال الحرائق ويحاولون
عرقله قوات من اللحاق بهم من خلال هذه
الحرائق التي يشعلونها في كل الاحياء وفي
كل الشوارع في العاصمه باريس حقيقه الحراك
الطلابي هو مهم في هذه المرحله هناك عدد
كبير من الكليات والجامعات تقوم باضرابات
الطلاب يقومون ايضا بتنفيذ عصيان في عدد
كبير من هذه الجامعات واليوم هناك اعلان
عن اكثر من 500 مدرسه ثانويه واعداديه
ايضا تنفذ هذا الاضراب لدعم المحتجين
ومطالب النقابات
[موسيقى]
للاحتجاج على نافع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما